Jack Ryan is an Amazon Prime original
series starring John Krasinski based on
the works of Tom Clancy the show tackles
issues such as terrorism foreign policy
biological warfare and more throughout
this video I will be discussing the
first season of the show in fall as well
as how the work ties into the movies and
what could come down the line there will
be heavy spoilers so it may be worth
skipping this video for now if you want
to go in with fresh eyes with that out
the way I'm definition and this is my
ending explained video but Jack Ryan
season one Jack Ryan season one follows
the titular character in his hunt for
the Sulaiman an extremist Muslim that
Ryan believes could be the next bin
Laden after the terrorist launches a
biological attack in France the stakes
rise exponentially and Ryan is tasked
with bringing the Suleiman to justice
with help from his captain agent Korea
sorry I mean officer Greer
Ryan manages to catch up with the
terrorists wife as she is attempting to
cross the border under the guise of
being a political refugee through his
investigation Ryan learns that the
Suleiman has managed to obtain a deadly
strain of Ebola which he plans to
contaminate u.s. hostages with Suleiman
realizes that if he allows ground troops
to rescue the hostages that they will
eventually come into contact with the
president due to his close relationship
with the head kidnapping this will cause
the president to become infected with
the disease which will spread to his top
aides Congress and more it will require
intense medical care and has the
potential to completely disable eyes the
government in addition to this he
launches another attack in the US that
is intended solely to cause confusion
and
chaos ordering his right-hand man to
bomb a pizza Paula as a diversion the
suleiman seems to be one step ahead of
his enemies however rhine concludes that
this is merely a distraction from the
terrorists real end game similar to his
attack in paris on the priest
the restaurant bombing has been carried
out to provide cover for their real plan
this has been a multi-step process the
entire time and the terrorist true plan
is to release cesium within the hospital
that the president is being treated at
deadlier than Ebola when released
through the ventilation ducts it will
immediately kill all those that comes
into contact with Ryan realizes the
master plan however and the CIA evacuate
the hospital chasing Suleiman through
the subway Ryan dodges trains and
bullets and manages to bring the
terrorists down by using the dirty
tactic of announcing that he has his son
Suleiman dies at the scene and Ryan
returns his son to the rest of his
family this highlights the arc that he
has went on as Ryan believed that
children could also be swayed by the war
due to one earlier in his career killing
his teammates in a helicopter rescue the
series ends with the surviving soldiers
of Suleiman being hunted down by Matisse
a French intelligence officer who wants
revenge on those who committed the
attacks in Paris Greer goes to Moscow
and Ryan is promoted to the head of t
fed if you're a fan of the Jack Ryan
films and fiction and then you know that
the character doesn't exactly have much
to look forward to outside of the show
Ryan has been featured in five films
including the hunt for the Red October
Patriot Games clear and present danger
the sum of all fears and jack ryan
shadow recruit was all are great films
and each one is an easy choice to take
the series into down the line I
personally believe that the most likely
course of action that season two will
take is that of the sum of all fears in
the sum of all fears terrorists detonate
a nuclear bomb in the city of Baltimore
during a football game and it destroys
the city and almost kills the president
the terrorists frame Russia in an
attempt to cause World War 3 and this is
definitely an aspect that could
metaphorically work alongside a lot of
real-world fears that America currently
has about the country Russia is often
brought up when discussing the election
of President Trump and I think it would
be the perfect thing to do a second
season on with Korea being relocated to
Russia this is definitely a place Ryan
could come to as a that later down the
line however there is also the potential
that Ryan could go on a hunt for the Red
October route which involves evacuating
a defect in general from Soviet waters
we will just have to wait and see what
happens so what did you think of Jack
Ryan season one have you seen the other
films featuring the character and how
would you rank it amongst them comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and
subscribe to my channel I create content
like this weekly and they'll definitely
be something on here that you love if
you're a fan of TV I recently discussed
the post-credits scene of sharp objects
starring Amy Adams so make sure you
check that out next again thanks for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]